y llegamos a marruecos donde la
presencia del terrorismo yihadista en
áfrica sobre todo en el sahel centra la
reunión ministerial de la coalición
contra el estado islámico organizada en
marrakech ahí se encuentra nuestra
corresponsal sofía catalá sofía muy
buena tarde primero hablemos entonces
del tema principal de este encuentro el
incremento de la inseguridad de los
grupos terroristas en el sahel y cuál es
la situación en esa región sofía
si raúl a marruecos arbitra a este año
en la reunión ministerial como dice s de
la coalición internacional contra el
daes que se centra precisamente en
abordar la evolución de los grupos de
terroristas de corte yihadista en la
región africana del sahel y es que tras
la derrota de estos grupos terroristas
en siria e irak ahora estados unidos y
sus aliados buscan dicen de estabilizar
el al sahel incrementando sus
intervenciones militares y también la
cooperación a nivel financiero a la
cimera a esta cumbre perdona ha venido
delegaciones de los 83 estados miembros
de la coalición se han visto por aquí
muchos ministros de exteriores de países
de la unión europea y también la
subsecretaria de estado de estados
unidos victoria nuland estaba prevista
la asistencia del propio secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken pero no
pudo venir porque a ese infectó de kobe
19 y en el sahel precisamente raúl egea
se registraron más del 48 por ciento del
total de muertes por terrorismo a nivel
global en el año 2 21 siendo malí en
níger y burkina faso los territorios más
afectados por el avance de estos grupos
y cabe entender el avance adela del
terrorismo pues por motivos económicos
sociales y políticos por ejemplo estos
tres países a los que nos referimos mali
burkina faso y níger están entre los
diez más pobres del mundo según su
índice de desarrollo humano eso a pesar
de tener reservas muy importantes por
ejemplo de oro y uranio que en realidad
son explotadas por empresas extranjeras
y también los expertos apuntan como
motivo o sea de la inseguridad en el
sahel pues a la ausencia de los estados
por ejemplo en las zonas más rurales de
estos países también la corrupción la
falta de desarrollo de lo local y las
intervenciones y retiradas precipitadas
de ejércitos extranjeros entre otras
cuestiones serán fundamentales sofía le
pregunto por qué marruecos como sede de
este encuentro ministerial la
importancia de hemos recogido este esta
problemática
pues si marruecos al que preside de
hecho junto a eeuu italia y a níger el
áfrica focus group que dentro de lo que
es la coalición contra el tae se centra
concretamente en a la seguridad del
sahel además omar huecos pues es un
aliado muy importante a eeuu y de la
unión europea aquí en el norte de áfrica
y también en los últimos años se ha
convertido en un actor crucial para la
cooperación económica en el sahel y
sobre todo también la cooperación
religiosa y es que mar hueco se lucha
activamente contra el expansionismo de
la ideología islamista wahabita que
digamos choca con las tradiciones más
moderadas y místicas del islam que
serían el sufismo y la escuela malikí
que de hecho imperaba en el sahel
históricamente antes de el avance de
estos grupos terroristas y por otra
parte cabe destacar pues que convertirse
en un actor fundamental para la
seguridad en el sahel pues a marruecos
también le podría valer para alcanzar
otras metas diplomáticas por ejemplo en
lo referente al conflicto del sáhara
occidental y también para intentar hacer
prevalecer su hegemonía en el norte
frente a su vecino argelino